il était au front durant l'assaut du
capitole
[Applaudissements]
des membres de groupes extrémistes comme
les profs brésil est hot nipples
certains vêtus d'équipement militaire
aurait pu faire encore plus de dégâts
comment en sont ils arrivés là
le 14 décembre 2020 le collège électoral
représentant les 50 états a officialisé
le résultat de l'élection tenue un mois
plus tôt joe biden était le président
désigné en actions
selon le comité de nanchang savait qu'il
avait perdu mais tentait de s'accrocher
au pouvoir certains de ses conseillers
lui ont dit comment faire
durant l'une des rencontres les plus
folles de sa présidence dutil ceni
parole michael flynn et d'autres se sont
rendus dans le bureau ovale ils ont
accompagné le président dans les salles
adjacentes et dans sa résidence pour lui
proposer entre autres de saisir des
machines à compter les votes
l'avocat de la maison blanche présents à
cette réunion considéré qu'il s'agissait
d'une idée terrible elle a finalement
été écartée mais quelques heures plus
tard dans un tweet invité ses partisans
à washington le 16 janvier
soyez là ce sera fou écrit-il la
réaction est immédiate
cet homme qui est entré par effraction
au capitole dit l'avoir fait sur ordre
du président
ça aurait pu être le début d'une
nouvelle guerre civile croit l'ancien
porte-parole des hôtes people des
membres de cette milice d'extrême droite
communiquer avec des proches de monsieur
tron avant le 6 janvier dont radio stone
et michael flynn photos et messages
textes à l'appui
quand monsieur jack nous a demandé de
battre en retraite dit il nous l'avons
fait alors pourquoi le président n'at-il
pas dit à ses partisans de quitter le
capitole plus tôt l'assaut a duré 187
minutes que faisait dans notre job au
juste durant ses 187 minutes le comité
tentera de répondre à cette question
dans une prochaine audience la semaine
prochaine ici sébastien desrosiers
radio-canada washington